the Trump administration can slow down
marijuana legalization but they can't
stop it I think medical should happen I
don't we agree I mean I think so and
then I really believe you should leave
it up to the states it should be a state
situation first of all the federal
government doesn't have the power to
force States to make marijuana illegal
again so even if they say filed a
lawsuit to challenge the system of
licensing and regulation they might
knock that out if they were successful
with that lawsuit but that doesn't mean
that marijuana is banned again in those
states
it just means is unregulated so from
their point of view I'm not sure that
that's any better a lot of people are
worried that the Trump administration
will crackdown on marijuana legalization
mainly because of the ban he chose for
Attorney General Jeff Sessions who is an
old-style drug warrior marijuana is not
the kind of thing that ought to be
legalized good people don't smoke
marijuana he could indeed crack down on
a lot of marijuana businesses and states
where it's legal that would obviously
have it has a very disrupting effect on
the industry what would be not just hard
but impossible would be to go after all
the people producing and distributing
marijuana because in almost all the
states that have legalized it for
recreational use you're allowed to grow
your own at home the federal government
wouldn't have the manpower to go up
after all these home growers the federal
government has never had the resources
to actually enforce prohibition for the
most part they relied overwhelmingly on
the states almost all the arrests were
done by the state so they can create a
lot of chaos but ultimately they're not
going to reverse legalization and bring
back prohibition there's really very
little upside politically for Trump to
go after a legal marijuana its first of
all inconsistent with what he said
during the campaign secondly it's
inconsistent with conservative
principles and so far as conservatives
believe that states should be able to
make their own policies with respect to
things that happen within the state and
he is going contrary to public opinion
because the polls show a majority of
Americans support legalization social
conservatives might be pleased by a
crackdown on marijuana but he has
placated them in various other ways
already so I would do that's the only
benefit I can see and it's very big
downside
you